bueno estamos ante un nuevo episodio no
detenciones entre irán e israel uno más
que se suma ya a una larga lista donde
cree usted que podríamos encontrar el
origen de las confrontaciones directas
suerte de enemistad entre israel e irán
bueno hay varios elementos el primer
elemento fundamental es entender las
alianzas internacionales en primer lugar
irán éstá en alianza con china que más
cerca en una alianza china rusia
y israel está claramente alineado con
eeuu en principio pero eso no podría
decir lo que se ya hemos ha dominado la
política los últimos diez años pero me
parece a mí que el elemento más
importante de todos estos estas idas y
vueltas que incluyen por ejemplo el
agravamiento de la sanción a irán por
parte de la unión europea por hechos que
sucedieron hace casi dos años un año y
medio el tienen que ver en realidad con
las negociaciones por intentar reflotar
el acuerdo nuclear que se ha firmado en
el 2015 en viena entre francia alemania
reino unido china rusia los eeuu y
obviamente ir a un acuerdo que permitía
una serie de ventajas económicas sobre
todo sobre todo para la unión europea
recordemos que empresas como daimler
como la banco bnp paribas como varias
automotrices citroën renault peugeot
bueno la empresa pese apoyo reino de psa
peugeot citroën y reinó entre entre
otras tantas bueno en la petroquímica
total
pensado en ese periodo luego del acuerdo
un gran una gran inversión en irán
ese acuerdo fue roto por donald trump en
2018 y llevo obviamente al retiro de
ciertos de esas inversiones sobre todo
europeas y varias inversiones
norteamericanas de hecho el agua digamos
se han realizado sanciones a empresas
europeas por parte del gobierno
norteamericano y ahora con la llegada de
biden se intenta intentar reflotar el
acuerdo de hecho hay un plan macro macro
nintento un plan para afrontar el
acuerdo vaya bien dijo que estaba
dispuesto a reflotar el acuerdo
obviamente las partes no se ponen para
ganancia de acuerdo porque eeuu dice que
el primero que tiene que dar el paso es
irán y gran dice que el primero que
tiene que dar estar mezclados sueños
en ese marco aparece gente contrario se
reflote de acuerdo como israel o arabia
saudita recordemos los enfrentamientos
que se están dando y sostenidos por irán
y eeuu en yemen
el líbano y en irak entonces en ese
barco es el les toma y daca en el cual
se está negociando ese acuerdo y si
precisamente sobre el pacto nuclear no
de 2015 va a apuntar la próxima pregunta
y sobre las sanciones de la unión
europea no crea usted que estas
sanciones de la unión europea a
funcionarios iraníes por presuntas
violaciones a los derechos humanos
podrían socavar estos intentos de que
teherán cumpla con el pacto nuclear
a mí me parece que estas sanciones son
parte de la negociación
no es la unión europea no está digamos
por así decirlo rompiendo la mesa de
negociación es parte de las
negociaciones decir bueno lo sancionó
estos funcionarios como forma de presión
a irán a que firme los acuerdos y
obviamente si se realizan los acuerdos
estas acciones se levantarán o se
minimizarán o quedaron en la nada
recordemos son sanciones a personas que
están en irán es decir hay un punto en
el cual son sanciones que van a tener
poca efectividad diferentes plantear las
sanciones al comercio con irán
eso sería diferente pero déjenme acotar
una cuestión importante que es una de
las grandes trabas al acuerdo una traba
al acuerdo es son los intereses de
arabia saudita israel o mejor dicho los
intereses norteamericanos en arabia
saudita israel pero hay otro elemento
importante que tiene que ver con una
traba que al acuerdo y en la relación
china rusia irán porque porque en la
medida en la cual el trump retiró a eeuu
del acuerdo y obligó de alguna forma
la unión europea a ir retirándose en el
acuerdo obtener una situación ambigua se
intensificó la relación entre china
rusia e irán sobre todo con china